so let's just talk about the system of
politics because you're an insider and
an outsider so when you were the
chairman of the Republican Party how
much of the job how much of your
day-to-day was just about money
because that's what this is really all
well okay so literally yes so let's be
clear the the role of any party chairman
Democrat Republican counties state
national is two things they only have
two things raise money and win elections
if you don't do that you're not doing
your job
so your day is made up of doing those
two things that is 80 percent of your
day in on a good day yeah where you will
spend anywhere from two to four hours
dialing for dollars which there very few
of us like doing because it's just tough
to raise I look I'm calling I'm asking
you for $38,000
okay there's a lot of presumption in
that conversation right all right and
cuz that's the maximum you can give did
they give you a list I mean right when
we got there first day they're like
here's that yeah you get get I got I was
elected on a Friday and that Monday I
went up to New York and did a town hall
on health care and the economy and that
Tuesday I was at my desk really
officially for the first time at the
desk and I did three and a half hours
worth of calls for for donors then what
I did was it was the idea was I needed
to introduce myself to these folks cuz
I'm the new kid on the block
and you know for some of them I was a
little bit more of a shock than they
anticipated and and so it was more
introduction but then yeah you kind of
roll into and I actually had a donor
cussed me out and said you know I'm so
sick of the party every time I hear from
you people is when you call asking for
money I'm not giving you another damn
dime Dada Dada and I let him beg his
brother went on for like 20 bucks
let him talk and then I said well
actually I wasn't calling to ask for
money I was just calling to introduce
myself and but I wouldn't have you
wouldn't have said no to the money he
was
give me money yeah so but but this was
the point and this is another important
lesson of how you I think you do this
right so I listen to this man because
here is a longtime donor an activist in
the party a supporter who is now ticked
off at its leadership at the political
operations and once no part of it so I
told him I said well look I tell you I'm
putting together a business plan which
is what I did I put together business
cuz I'm a business guy so I put together
a business plan for the party and said
we gotta raise money and this one how we
gonna spend it these are things that are
priorities mm-hmm and I got that
together over a period of time but I
told him I was doing it I also told laid
out to him what I wanted to do what my
vision was and I so look I don't want
your money
I said you wait and see if I do the job
to your satisfaction and if you feel
like give and give us give us a check
two weeks later you sent a check for the
maximum amount because because and he
told me in his note he said you listened
to me you took the time to listen to me
and so I thought about that and that is
the big difference listening to people
goes so goes so far and so the money
piece is a big part now I believe money
is property I just generally do that's
my philosophical view like any of
anything else I own I should be free to
do with it as I wish that doesn't say
this shouldn't be limitations i Susan
this is great now you'll love this yeah
so the RNC had a lawsuit and that I took
over when I became chairman to to
basically peel back on mccain-feingold
because mccain-feingold took away from
the parties the ability to raise the
money all right
and they created this system that we
have in of course there was a companion
lawsuit guess what it was for more money
in no no what was the companion lawsuit
anyone Supreme Court rejected my lawsuit
and picked up yeah right so so citizens
united was that was the case they
decided to take over the one that we've
given the money required donors to give
untold sums as they used
to the state parties to the national
parties in the state parties and they
decided to go down this road where you
could set up these 527s which we are now
living through is a nightmare yes I want
to get to that in just a sec but I think
everyone wants to know how much does the
money how much influence does it
actually get you so someone writes a 38
thousand dollar check or someone writes
goes to the shrimp yeah I mean really
what what do you get them what do you
really get well with the part again
separating the party I'm the candidate
yeah when you write a check to the RNC
we gonna take care of you right all
right cuz that's what we do that's what
we're supposed to do and what is that so
we notice that when you call up and want
to talk to the Chairman you get to talk
to the Chairman when you now
you don't bring issues to me because
we're political we're not policy so you
can and some do I mean I you know
buckets of ideas that people are a I
think we should do this that's fine but
that's a separate way to operate that's
that's that's all political you know it
it's it's what it is I you know we wanna
we dine you we we take you out and we we
do big fundraisers we do small
fundraisers we're in your home all
that's part of that and of course the
access you get so when you have
convention guess what you're gonna be
taken care of because you're a major
donor to the party
yeah you're going to be invited to the
suite you're going to get a chance to
meet the candidates fan thing you know
the nominees family and all of that
stuff that's what we do there's nothing
wrong with that we've been doing that
since the days of Jefferson and
Washington and all those guys alright so
that's not unusual what's changed now is
this dynamic where you have
organizations that can be created that
ostensibly don't talk to the candidate
right which we know is complete [ __ ]
right of course yeah you know you know
everybody you know my my former chief of
staff is now in the head of my super PAC
yeah you don't think I'm talking to this
guy at some point right all right so
we'll look we'll we'll go with the lie
we'll go with the fiction that it
doesn't happen but what what it does do
is and I'm and I have to be honest with
everyone I'm still evolving in a way on
this subject because of how I view money
generally but money and politics are
nice
what it is doing it's making it harder
it is becoming more of a distraction at
the end of the day whether you're Rupert
Murdoch or you know some other big
liberal or conservative donor you get
one vote
you get one vote you know you don't get
you know 38,000 votes because you devote
a check for $30,000 and I get what about
but now you can put a lot of money to
put a lot of ads on fox or CNN or MSNBC
that influenced a lot of other people
well you know okay so let's talk about
that do you are you really influenced by
political ads anyone I mean do you know
if you saw an ad tearing him down if
he's a candidate for office and saying
that you know he hates puppies do you
not true do you really do you really
walk away from that ad thinking he hates
puppies I really do but that's my point
I mean it I'm not saying it doesn't work
but what I'm saying and Willie Horton by
the way it was originally a Democrat ad
in their primary so we won't we won't
have that that's a whole other yeah
that's a whole nother discussion I
thought they liked to put that on our
doorstep but listen let's go to the
origins of the Willie Horton ad but the
but you're right it works so what does
that say about us yeah what does that
say about you the consumer I I mean I
just I get my point is this is the yin
and the yang so the political class
takes advantage of as much as they can
because they know a negative ad is going
to work no matter how much you protest
against it no matter how much you hate
it you're gonna sit there like this wow
did you see and then you're gonna did
you see that now today you're gonna
tweet about it you're gonna you're gonna
send it out so they know that they play
to that and and that's part of that part
of the problem and the money does that
what I tried to do is chairman and we
were moderately successful in the last
cycle in 2012 but we set it up in my
term in 20 2009 and 10 was I
I saw down the road that money was going
to be an issue particularly after
Supreme Court rejected my case and took
citizens united so we wanted to design a
system so that you could actually
participate
not necessarily have to have a lot of
money and we saw that with Newt Gingrich
Rick Santorum and a number of candidates
in the 2012 cycle who didn't have Mitt
Romney's bankroll but because of the way
the system was designed they had time to
get their idea out there and those ideas
began to resonate and that's when the
money came to them after the fact so
there is this dynamic that that you can
play around with right now is I will
argue and agree with you it's distorted
yeah and there needs to be a
reassessment of how we use money in
politics and and right now I I think
it's it's used poorly because it's just
way way too much of it yeah so last
question about about money do you think
both parties treat it the same I think
there's a sense and this may be just a
meme down there yeah that you know that
the Koch brothers run the Republican
Party there's more of like there's the
evil mr. burns guys that are running the
party more than say the Democrats I am a
firm believer that it's got equal how
much money did Hollywood how much money
did the unions how much money did
individual wealthy donors give Barack
Obama into Barack Obama who as a u.s.
senator was up on the Senate floor
beating the hell out of Republicans over
campaign finance reform talking all this
smack about oh yeah you know take the
public money until he got a big-ass
check and then all of a sudden winning
was when it became time to make that
decision what did his campaign decide to
do they didn't take public money in 2008
like McCain did right what did they do
this baby so fall the super PAC money
but even though there weren't super PACs
right they took all that money out of
Hollywood they took all that money off
of Wall Street so don't talk to me about
money in the Republican Party about
money in the political system that's
that's the reality because both sides
love it both sides suck at that teeth
every single day politically and maybe
otherwise and that that is that's the
reality that we're now having to live
with so you know talk about big money
it's just now manifesting itself in a
different form
because for 40 years with the you
ian's and hollywood were backing
Democrats Republicans weren't I mean we
didn't have we didn't have all these big
players the way we do now we didn't have
the Koch brothers back in in in in
Ronald Reagan's day or in in the 1970s
so the dynamic has changed a little bit
has actually changed a lot but the
thread the meme is the same yeah and
that is money still plays a role in
politics the question that we need to
ask ourselves again in in setting up our
scales of priorities is how do we prior
prioritize its role because if you're
going to go to a public in public
financing system then you need to
account for races that are in markets
like this market here in LA that is
damned expensive versus a market in Utah
or a market in southwest corner of South
Carolina is this an example where Obama
really has dropped the ball because even
just yesterday he went to Oregon where
the shooting was a couple days ago and
do you guys know where he went right
after that he went to a fundraiser this
is I mean think about that he's almost
after every national tragedy goes to a
fundraiser I don't know whose scheduling
this guy this is a second term president
with only a year left who after this
horrific tragedy I don't know who's
raised him on who's he raise the money
for I guess for the party right Debbie
says they're broke so I don't know isn't
that the most emblematic thing of what's
going on here that even a two-term
president on his way out goes to a
tragedy and then at the end of the day
his day was spent raising money and not
even for himself yeah I mean I think I
think that is something that that really
sticks in the craw of a lot of people
and and I can tell you it's as many
conservatives and and libertarians are
as annoyed about that as our liberals
and progressives and and so it is it is
an American phenomenon that we invest so
much of our politics in having money to
do politics yeah when you look at the
way politics is executed around the
globe this don't come anywhere near what
we spend to elect someone to office you
think about how much money I
candidate running for I was with the
candidate yesterday in New Hampshire
looking at a congressional race ask them
how much it's gonna run how much it's
gonna cost me in New Hampshire for
congressional two million dollars then
you have you in New Hampshire yeah for a
job that pays 170 thousand dollars a
year when I ran for the US Senate in
2006 my race was the most expensive race
in the state of Maryland up to that
point for the for federal office and I
raised ten million dollars for US Senate
races today for 2016 that race is now
about a 15 to 20 million dollar race why
crazy why and no one stops to ask the
question to answer the question why why
is it that expensive right there right -
and they need to continue to ask it
because you know it is having I think a
very downward depressive effect on our
politics it brings out the cynicism in
all of us because you just see a very
small group of people who are getting to
play and you're the one paying the taxes
you're the one trying to make it from
paycheck to paycheck you're the one
who's trying to deal with all this crap
that spews out of state capitals and in
federal government and you just feel
that your access is somehow limited and
cut off and no Americans should feel
that way in my view yeah alright enough
about money money it's important it's
important but and we could talk about it
forever is important it is important but
it's it's one of those things I don't
you tell me how you get it out of the
game yeah how do you how do you get out
of the game at this point because under
the current rules under the current
rules because as long as you've got a
citizens united out there where you you
you and you can get together and decide
we're going to form a pact and it may
not be for candidate a or candidate B
you just want to form a pact and you
just want to play and you're gonna go to
the rest of the universe and you can now
raise untold millions of dollars and we
don't need to know who any one of you
are you can stroke a check for ten
million dollars right now and your name
would never show up on any report in
Washington do we really want that system
I believe very again going back to my
and we can then move on yeah going back
to my central argument money is property
so I can do with my property whatever I
want right so if I want to write your
campaign a ten million dollar check
alright I should be allowed to do it but
here's the caveat here's the catch the
day I write it the next morning the next
hour the next minute it is fully
disclosed period my name what I do the
amount the nature of my business so that
everyone in the universe knows who's
giving to you and then that puts the
onus on you the politician because if
you want to be associated with my money
and all that comes with it
guess what you'll take it but if you
don't guess what you won't and that will
have a chilling effect because right now
if you don't know that I'm doing
something that you know harms the
environment or otherwise is you know a
negative for example no one in the
universe will ever know it except you
when you write the check when you get
the check I'm pretty sure the
politicians like the plausible
deniability always they do yeah so all
right so moving away from money so I
want talk about foreign policy a little
bit because to me it should be a
Republican there should be a go to
Republican issue and we're in a freaking
mess right now I mean I don't think the
American public really realizes what a
public an issue well well that they're
stronger you know executive branch sets
the foreign policy so why is this of
sure but there's the the idea that
Republicans are stronger in foreign
policy and we have such a meltdown right
and we gave that up a while ago we gave
that we gave that position up a while
ago when we were started making some
some some really boneheaded decisions
about how we engage right so Iraq right
so so I mean it's just it's just a bad
policy you don't you don't do nation
building no no super power since time
began has been successful in
nation-building yeah it always it always
collapses at some point it falls down
around your feet so where do you fall
then on everything that's going on in
the Middle East we tried to nation-build
right we know we
to the wrong war for the wrong reasons
is that fair to say
yeah and now because of that Iraq but
especially Syria they're not functioning
States in any way that we define it well
yeah you look at it in two parts and in
the first part we all know the history
we all know how we got here all right so
that's that's stipulated we all know how
we got here and I think generally
everyone including candidates now
running for president on the GOP side
sumber grudgingly some less so admit
that we've we got here the wrong way all
right so we're in a bad space for the
wrong reasons
all right so now the test of this time
is how do we go forward and how do we
what do we learn from the mistake and
then how do we not make it again
but more importantly how do we position
the United States visa vie our allies
like like Israel and Saudi Arabia who
you know represent to two opposing
problems for for the US and our enemies
like Iran which I really don't want to
use that term because that's a little
strong yeah you know that's a little
strong because that did it's not I don't
think it's there you know I don't think
is that kind of given 150 billion
dollars I don't think is that kind of
relationship yeah and and and the
strategic relationship we need to have
with Russia and China who are big
players in the Middle East but so are
the French yeah so are the Brits so all
right where does that leave us as a
nation because it seems to me that we go
in we try something we always screw it
up and now we leave and we see what that
does I mean it's a real mess there and
we created it so I feel like there's
there's a guilt sort of associated with
Americans we feel like we have to do
something and yet we know no matter what
we do we somehow make it worse and now
Russia is jumping in and Andrea Said's
and and I you know I you know we can
argue the point
I think there there are enough examples
of either hesitation by this
administration the Obama administration
reticence or even just a lack of
unawareness which they even alluded to
just recently about the the maneuvers of
Russia when you have State Department
officials off the record saying we just
didn't see this coming dude that's why
you're there you're supposed to see this
coming but or they call them JV I
wouldn't call Isis a JV but let me tell
you what I think this goes back to this
goes back to believe it or not to the
1970s in my view when the the Church
Committee and the Carter Administration
sort of came to this community
our intelligence organizations were
somehow bad now they you know CIA and
all those guys yeah they had their
fingers and some crazy pots and doing
some crazy things we got that but I
think what we what we are what we have
seen over time whether it's Iran Contra
whether it is what we're seeing right
now in in the Middle East is a lack of
intelligence on the ground a lack of
ability to actually know what the hell
is going on and I don't just mean know
who the bad players are but know what
nook and cranny they're in no know what
their favorite cafe is know what their
favorite coffee or latte is know know
who their kids I mean just that level of
detail
that was so much a part of the Cold War
in terms of how the US and Russia sort
of worked off of each other and knew
what was going on and they were so
effective at it that they created a
effectively a stalemate yeah so whose
fault is that that we don't have that oh
I think it's I think it's I think it's a
combination of of political leadership
that sort of overreacted to bad things
that that you know some of these
institutions get into and and and do you
know government is about overreaction
it's about reaction it's not Pro it's
not a proactive entity they just don't
submit it you think they sit around said
so listen how do we actually solve a
problem
four it starts that's it's not that's
not what they do yeah so you know a new
town happens a Columbine happens you
know a Freddie gray happens these things
happen and then the government wants to
come work now we're gonna come here
we're gonna fix this for you don't worry
we got this now actually not to step out
I'll just let the people on the ground
deal with it so there's there's a little
bit of that where they overreact and
they overreact in a way in which they
actually wind up making it worse
and in the process of overreacting they
begin to penalize the players in a way
that prevents them from doing anything
constructive later on yeah because now
we're gonna cut your funding for this
we're gonna bring you in for all this
here if they just did day-to-day
week-to-week month-to-month oversight
they have committees called oversight
yeah do they meet do they actually do
oversight who's oversight
if you're doing this on an ongoing basis
and you're sort of you're supporting and
guiding those those intelligence
organizations a lot of the stuff that
we've gotten ourselves into over the
last 15 20 years some of that could have
been avoided because we would have had
the intelligence to know I mean look at
look at it this way you know how many
times have we seen in the political
process when you don't have the count
right on something or you you've
misidentified something or you miss
brand that's okay there are no
consequences from that all right so the
speaker didn't get that vote because the
whip didn't count it right okay we got
that but when you're out in the field
when you're when you're in a situation
like Benghazi for example where you have
cables from from the people in the field
saying we need this support and the
folks in Washington want to have a
meeting about it that's where the things
begin to break down and so there's this
idea of having an ongoing accountable
oversight process in which you are you
are in the moment real-time with what's
going on I think begins to alleviate the
pressure on the executive branch and
even the Congress to put itself
a position where you know we're talking
about sending in troops and you know
ratcheting up all the spending on on you
know in reaction to something that
someone else has done I think that's a
step net you know we're always playing
catch-up I think we're playing catch-up
and it's more complicated I know and
then there's a lot more to it but it's
you know I tell you I've learned over
the years in Washington and certain
watching some of these guys it's always
the simple stuff you know it's it's the
things that you don't think are
important or the things that you just
kind of got why are we why would we do
that that's the thing you should do to
avoid a bigger problem later on